تجربه مختبريه غير مسبوقه على مستوى
العالم نتائجها تبشر بثوره طبيه التجربه
لعلماء بريطانيين نجحوا في انتاج دم بشري
من خلايا جذعيه بشريه بالايضا قاموا بنقل
ذلك الدم الى مرضى وبحسب العلماء في جمعتي
كامبردج وبرسل فان النتائج الاوليه مبشره
من خلال عدم رفض اجسام المرضى للدم المصنع
المنقول تدريجيا على مدار الاشهر المقبله
لاستكشاف ماذا كفاءه الدم المصنوع مختبريا
ومن بين مزايا الطريقه الجديده التي
ابتكرها الباحثون انها تسمح باختيار فصيله
الدم التي يريدونها فضلا عن انتاج الكميات
التي يريدونها ايضا المزيد في الشرح
الثاني
يمكن ان تحدث خلايا الدم المصنعه التي
تثبت من خلايا الجذعيه للمتبرعين ثوره في
العلاجات لكثير من الاشخاص ومنهم الاشخاص
الذين يعانون من الترامات الدم مثل 300
ايضا المصابون مرض فقر الدم المنجلي اي
انتاج خلايا الدم حمراء غير طبيعيه الشكل
كذلك المرضى الذين يعتمدون طوال الوقت على
عمليات النقل المنتظمه او تبادل الخلايا
الحمراء هؤلاء المرضى اعدادهم في تزايد
ويحتاج بعض الاشخاص لما يصل الى اثنا عشر
وحده من الدم كل اربعه الى سته اسابيع كما
ان مزود الخدمات الطبيه يعانون باستمرار
من نقص في المتبرعين وبالتالي قد يكون
ايضا خيارا علاجيا لاولئك المرضى لديهم
فصائل دم نادره لان الدم المصنع سيسمح
باختيار فصائل الدم التي تزرع في المختبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنى من بريطانيا رئيس الباحثين بروفيسور
سيدرك استاذ طب نقل الدم واستشاري امراض
الدم في جامعه
الاعضاء دكتور يسعد صباحك شكرا على تواجدك
معنا اهلا
طيب دكتور اختراق علمي غير مسبوغ يعني
الاول عالميا نجاح تجربه صناعه دم بشري
مصنع مختبريا للمره الاولى يعني حدثنا عن
اهميه هذه التجربه وان من المستفيد منها
تحديدا
اهميه هذه التجارب هي لان تظهر المراه
الاولى ان ان نستطيع ان نصنع خلايا الدم
الحمراء داخل المختبرات من الخلايا
الجذعيه بكميات كبيره في
التجارب على المتبرعين من البشر هذه مهمه
جدا خاصه للمرضى من لديهم انواع الدم
النادره ومن لصاحبي جدا الثوري على انواع
الدم المطابقه لهم فالان بامكاننا اختيار
الخلايا الجذعيه مع مجموعه المناسبه
والتطوير الخلايا لها المرضى
صدرك في فتره كرونه كان يقال عن من يحملون
في فصيله دم او بوزيتيف هم الاقل عرضه
للاصابه بكورونا بمعنى بان دمهم لديه
حصانه مناعيه ربما اكثر من غيرهم هل بهذه
الحاله يجب اخذ فصيله او فئه الدم دون
غيرها لهذه التجارب ولتطويرها مخبريا
لانتاج دم مخبري يعني مثلا ناخذ اوبوزيتيف
ولا ناخذ ايه بوزيت مثلا
قدام مجموعه الدهام وتاثيره كافه 19 لم
يكن نظرا او ناجما عن خلايا الدم الحمراء
اما في هذا المثال في مكان همم تطوير الدم
او تصنيعه او مطابقته مع فئه الدم التي
يحتاجها المريض فمثلا او نحنا جميع
المريض فهنا لك او مقارتين بدي
مقارنه همم سالب ومن ذلك نستطيع ان نصلي
على الخلايا
الدم الحمراء مستنسخه من خلايا جذعيه
بشريه هل يفهم انها لن تكون لها اي اثار
ضاره او جانبيه على جسد البشره
ويسنجر
تتصرف بنفس الشكل
مع مخاطر اقل في نقل الامراض ولكن الفائده
الكبرى هي من الخليه التي نصنعها في
المختبر ستدوم لفتره اطول في عمليه
التدوير فمثلا شخص مثلا لديه نقل دم
لاسبوعين وثلاثه اسابيع الان هذا هو عمر
الخلايا بسبب الامراض الموروثه ربما يتلقى
الدم الان بين سته الى ثمانيه اسابيع من
خلال هذا الدم المصنع
فهمت وبروفيسور صدرك كل متى يجب دمج هذا
الدم المصنع مثلا في اشخاص يعانون من
انيميا فقر دم او امراض مستعصيه نتحسن
نتحدث عن سرطان الدم هل يمكن ان يعالجها
الدم المغذى بخلايا الجذعيه
ما سيفعله هو انه سيجم فتره اطول في الدم
وفي دوران الدم ولا نعرف الفتره وهذا ما
تقوم به تجارب السريريه الان نحن ملعقتين
الان هو فيها الخلايا
مسلسل سيدك هل انت معنا طيب يبدا انا
فقدنا بروفيسور سيدركلي الحديث عن انتاج
دم مخبري وهو من ضمن الطاقم الطبي الذين
قاموا بهذه الثوره الطبيه بروفيسر سيدرك
جفيرتا استاذ طب نقل الدم استشاري امراض
الدم بجامعه كيبردج ومركز شكرا